[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
welcome to your weekly ticket
[Music]
the top two films over the halloween
weekend were the same as the previous
weekend with dune which just announced a
sequel coming in at number one with 16
million dollars and halloween kills
bringing in another 9 million halloween
ends which will close out not just the
new halloween trilogy but the franchise
as we know it and will release on
october 14th 2022 and denise velanov
will return to arrakis to film dune part
2 for its october 20th 2023 release date
the highest grossing new release was my
hero academia world heroes mission which
collected 6 million dollars at the
domestic box office
world heroes mission is the third film
based on the superhero manga series by
kohi horikoshi horikoshi's series also
spawned a popular television adaptation
which has run on adult swim since 2016.
all told with approximately 625 million
earned at the domestic box office
october 2021 was the highest grossing
month for theatrical films since
february 2020 brought us sonic to
hedgehog and birds of prey
venom let there be carnage and no time
to die where the two films to clear 100
million dollars for the month with the
venom sequel netting 190 million dollars
and the final daniel craig as james bond
entry earning 133 million dollars at the
u.s box office
from knives out to guns out ana de armas
is in talks to lead the john wick
spin-off titled ballerina len wiseman is
set to direct the film for lions gate
which will follow a young female
assassin who seeks revenge against the
people who killed her family the
character was briefly featured in john
wick chapter 3 parabellum as a young
dancer who is also trained to be an
assassin
it looks like bill murray will be headed
to the mcu the actor revealed the news
while promoting his latest film with wes
anderson the french dispatch when asked
about different directors he's
collaborated with over the years murray
said you know recently i made a marvel
movie but quickly followed up saying i
probably won't tell you but never mind
the star went on to mention being
attracted to the role because of
director peyton reed seemingly
confirming the mcu film as being the
third installment of ant-man and the
wasp starring paul rudd and evangeline
lilly and the director of independence
day roland emrick just released the
first footage of his new sci-fi film
moonfall halle berry and patrick wilson
star as astronauts out to save earth
from destruction moonfall is a sci-fi
disaster epic that follows former
astronaut turned nasa executive joe
fowler played by halle berry as she
uncovers the secret of the earth's
survival
in theaters this weekend is the latest
marvel adventure eternals marvel studios
eternals features an exciting new team
of superheroes in the marvel cinematic
universe ancient aliens who have been
living on earth in secret for thousands
of years following the events of
avengers end game an unexpected tragedy
forces them out of the shadows to
reunite against mankind's most ancient
enemy the deviants
and rotten tomatoes editor jacqueline
coley caught up with the cast who spoke
about their family and friend's reaction
to the news that they would be becoming
a marvel superhero now i have a friend
her name is samantha
and she is mexican and she is obsessed
with comics and superheroes and marvel
it's a grown woman mind you but she
knows everything she is obsessed
and i couldn't tell her for so long
oh because we had to keep quiet we have
to keep quiet yeah and i wanted to ask
her because she was going to give me the
bible of who i was
and that that one just like it was like
a telenovela she just
shook and cry and cry and cry she said
you're not joking no no
for real
and she was just uh by the way she said
director and she was just i like out of
her mind he was
really i can't wait for her to see it
strange to watch her i know
um and then i again i think i know but
why don't you tell me who had the best
reaction to you
really
i figured it would have been one of your
kids i knew who was who had the best
reaction
i mean i think i think my kids you know
what's so funny is when you're a mom and
you're such a mom
and they know me and they know me like
and i think there's that like that's so
great mom but like mom
you know so it became this like it was
going to be really fun i think they were
excited to
meet the other people excited to you
know for my family
the diversity within the cast
is so wonderful on for so many reasons
and it's just right and it's just due
time and it's
it just felt as it should very natural
and as it is
but it felt very nice from from my
family where i they're you know we just
it feels like a movie for them
yeah you know it's not
and and there's been lots of different
representation in different separate
films but not the same family
yeah all together in one family that
felt more
so for my family i was very happy to be
a part of this and that's that's part of
what i love about the diversity of it
that it is diverse but it's one family
yes and and
every in every family everybody is
different you can even if they look
alike yeah they have the same color even
everybody's different and it's
celebrated different it was emily my
wife you know because she was literally
the first one to know that she was the
first person i called um and you know
when they first called me and they said
hey so marvel wants to have a meeting
it's chloe zhao and nate moore and i
knew chloe was directing eternals and i
knew nate was producing it and emily was
like they don't want you to be a
superhero and i was like emily please
just calm down i don't think that's true
and i couldn't meet with them for a
couple weeks you know but but i had the
meeting they said we want you to play
this character and soon right afterwards
i called emily and she was just so
excited
ah and you know completely believed that
i could do it and honestly for months
the only people that knew were emily and
like you know the agents who have to do
the deal so so really really nobody knew
and i told my parents and i think they
kind of didn't believe that they were
like so which superhero i was like
ah kingo you haven't heard of him yet
but but there will be lego figures
plus lauren ridloff shared some easter
eggs about how she and her husband
douglas ridloff came up with the name
signs for each of the characters in the
film
we had worked in collaboration together
my husband and i um coming up with
different name signs for each of the
characters and i do have to let you know
that there are some easter eggs
for example kingo
i mean obviously
it's based on his power he shoots lasers
he has laser guns and then he also is a
bollywood dancer and so it's kind of
like a nice mix but
it also happened to be the name sign of
my youngest son
wyatt oh
and so yeah it's just between us it's a
nice little easter egg and then makari
so that's my character's name sign from
the face and it does represent speed
that she zooms that's what that sign
means
um and it's really close to the ear and
we picked that because i don't know if
you can see in the movie but makari
tends to wear a lot of earrings she has
these beautiful earrings on our ears and
so we based that from there
and in real life that happened to be the
name sign for my husband his name sign
is douglas
and theaters on friday is eternals and
spencer
[Music]
the marriage of princess diana and
prince charles has long since grown cold
though rumors of affairs and a divorce
abound peace is ordained for the
christmas festivities at the queen's
sandringham estate there's eating and
drinking shooting and hunting diana
knows the game but this year things will
be profoundly different spencer is an
imagining of what might have happened
during those few fateful days kristen
stewart stars as diana and sally hawkins
co-stars as her royal dresser the only
person in the house that she trusts
also available to watch at home is cry
macho and the eyes of tammy fay
you gonna say anything howard
i've always thought of you as a small
weak and gutless man
but you know there's no reason to be
rude cry macho stars clint eastwood as
mike milo a one-time rodeo star and
washed up horse breeder who in 1979
takes a job from an ex-boss to bring the
man's young son home from mexico
forced to take the back roads on their
way to texas the unlikely pair faces an
unexpectedly challenging journey during
which the world weary horseman finds
unexpected connections and his own sense
of redemption
alright well that's it for this week but
before you go leave us a comment and let
us know what you're watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you